[Musique]
baghdad aujourd'hui la situation est
devenue dangereuse et chaotique
nous vivons avec vous en direct ces
événements on entre on tombe saddam
hussein a été le principal pilleurs de
ce pays wigan et d'embouché vers 9
heures heure de l'est
la ce a annoncé avoir perdu tout contact
toute communication avec l'équipage
la nasa aurait perdu le contact avec
tous les détecteurs de paramètres
hydraulique squid voilà maintenant plus
de deux semaines que les premiers cas
canadiens ont été signalés
les jours passent et les autorités
ontariennes n'ose plus faire de
prédictions devant une situation de plus
en plus imprévisible à 21h10 15 secondes
radio canada prévoit que le prochain
gouvernement du québec la tendance se
maintient sera formée par le parti
libéral du québec et que ce sera un
gouvernement majoritaire
les parisiens et des touristes prennent
d'assaut tous les plans d'eau de la
ville la chaleur suffocante la canicule
s'abat sur tous les pays d'europe dans
les capitales on rivalise d'originalité
afin de trouver une façon de se
rafraîchir un peu le décès a été
apportée il y à peine de quelques heures
par qu'elle s'impliquait l'aller dans
les congrès fut
en contact direct avec le peuple marie
trintignant est morte ce matin à paris
on se souvient qu'elle a sombré dans un
profond coma des suites de graves
blessures subies lors d'une querelle
avec son ami bertrand cantat le chanteur
vedette du groupe rock noir désir qui
est soupçonné de l'avoir battue arar a
finalement été libéré l'homme d'origine
syrienne est en route ce soir vers le
canada je suis très content de revenir à
la maison
c'est bien connu les records sont faits
pour être battus et ceux d'éric gagné le
seront comme les autres en inscrivant
son nom sur le trophée cy young et
s'assure de laisser sa marque dans
l'histoire du liban
[Musique]